These guys realized quick,
if they were going to claim that
cigarettes were not addictive,
they better have proof.
This is the man who rely on,
he's been testing the link between
nicotine and lung cancer for 30 years
and hasn't found any conclusive results.
The man's a genius.
He could disprove gravity.
This is called industry funded research.
And while it is a science,
unfortunately,
it's oftentimes a science of deception
when faced with inconvenient facts,
companies will sometimes pay for
research to find the opposite conclusion
so they can deny guilt.
The most notorious example for this was
the tobacco industry who famously
created an organization called the
council for Tobacco Research to fight
the idea that cigarettes caused lung
cancer.
Uh,
Dr Liddle have any cancer causing agents
been identified and cigarettes?
No,
none had ever,
uh,
either in cigarette.
So in any of product of smoking.
As such.
Now,
fast forward a few decades,
the public eventually found out the
truth and the CTR was exposed as a sham,
but as the world turned it into
attention to new problems,
one industry found itself in familiar
crosshairs.
We Americans spend more money on slots
then on movies,
baseball and theme parks combined,
but with the modern slot machines,
there's a greater potential for a
dangerous side effect gambling
addiction.
Problem gambling has become an epidemic.
Last year,
the American Psychiatric Association,
we classified pathological gambling as
an addiction.
A Las Vegas and other casinos are like
giant laboratories and the features that
earn higher will stick and those that
don't will drop away.
The formula they've hit upon happens to
be one that's highly addictive.
The gambling industry was being accused
of preying on the wallets of addicted
gamblers,
addicted gamblers that they helped
create with their carefully designed
machines.
Howard Shaffer,
researcher at Harvard noted this
increased addictiveness of modern games
like slots by calling them the crack
cocaine of gambling.
In the midst of all this horrible press,
the gambling industry needed a strategy
to stay alive.
Luckily for them,
they had watched someone else go through
this and had learned a few things.
You can't completely deny the facts.
The cigarette industry tried it and it
didn't work.
The truth eventually comes out,
so they came up with a different plan.
Instead of denying gambling addiction,
they would embrace the problem publicly
and also take an extremely active role
in researching the science of gambling
addiction.
By doing this,
they could frame the discussion of the
addiction the way they wanted to and so
the National Center for responsible
gaming was created funded by casino
dollars,
and here's how they described gambling
addiction today,
so what exactly is a gambling disorder
and why do some people struggle with it
while others do not?
One point that research clearly shows is
that gambling disorders are closely
linked with other psychological
problems,
including depression and substance
abuse.
We also know that over time,
proximity to casinos does not impact the
prevalence of gambling disorders,
and one of the vast majority of people
gamble responsibly.
Approximately one percent of Americans
are diagnosed with a gambling disorder.
Now,
it might not surprise you.
Many of their findings are in direct
contradiction to scientific studies that
aren't backed by casino dollars,
but rather than nitpicking everything,
I want to focus on their macro message.
The biggest thing is that they want to
imply that addicts are born that way
they're not created from a product.
If you can blame addiction on brain
problems within the addict,
your indirectly vindicating the gambling
machines,
of course this is what the casinos want.
The most dangerous idea is that they
have anything to do with creating
addicts,
so instead they say it's not the product
that causes the problem.
The problem is already within the addict
and just expresses itself in the
addiction.
The senior research director for the
NCRG,
Christine Riley makes this bias
explicit.
Things are not addictive.
They're just not.
If you don't have that vulnerability,
the odds are you won't get addicted and
the NCRG is willing to put up a lot of
money to any scientist who will agree
with them and surprisingly one of the
people who took them up on that offer
was Howard Schaefer,
the main,
quoted it earlier as calling slots the
crack cocaine of gambling.
Today he tells a much different story
that casino games like slots aren't
addictive,
and if this seems like a one 80 to you,
you're not the only one.
When asked about this contradiction,
he tried really hard to square the two
opinions,
but at one point you said slot machines.
Where the crack cocaine of gambling and
how does that square with what you're
telling me today,
not everybody who uses crack cocaine
becomes addicted.
Nobody's going to sit here and try to
tell me crack cocaine isn't addictive
and if this is like crack cocaine,
the conclusion is that it's addictive.
I don't come to the same conclusion
because the majority of people that have
used cocaine have not developed cocaine
addiction.
Only a small minority.
And the same would be true with
gambling.
Oh,
okay.
Now obviously Howard shaffer would say
the millions of dollars in research
funding he's received hasn't tainted his
research,
but uh,
in Schaefer's words,
I,
I don't come to the same conclusion
because we started to say the wrong
things.
A lot of that funding would disappear.
Research funding from places like C or
g,
but also mgm resorts and draft kings
just to name a few.
And this strategy to by scientific
research to shift the burden of
responsibility onto the addict and away
from the product has been great for
casinos,
public image,
but it isn't the first time someone
tried it.
Assessment of the published data seemed
to show an association between certain
types of cancer and excessive use of
cigarettes.
Now,
very interested in finding out what kind
of people are heavy smokers.
Is it a different nervous type of
person?
Is it a person who is differently to
strain stress because it is very clear
that certain people just couldn't take
it.
Certain people just can't take it.
This is exactly the same framing casinos
use.
Why do some people struggle with it
while others do not?
Certain people just can't take it.
It's a simple,
powerful argument and whether or not
anyone fully believes them,
that isn't the point.
The gambling industry winds,
even if all they do is confuse you.
If they can cast doubt on the scientific
consensus of what causes gambling
addiction,
they've won because nobody's going to
legislate on something that the
scientific community isn't agreed upon
and the problem of deliberate
misinformation is widespread.
It goes beyond just smoking and
gambling.
You can find it at Exxon where knowledge
of climate change was deliberately
ignored and you can find it in the sugar
industry when they paid for research to
blame heart disease on fat instead of
sugar.
You can even find it in my favorite Soda
Company.
Coca Cola,
when they publicly said they care about
the problem of soft drinks,
but deny it in the science.
So if we know this problem is
widespread,
why do we continue to fall for it?
There are two main models we use to deal
with research that has a conflict of
interest.
You can completely prohibit it or you
can disclose the conflict of interest
and use peer review as a check and
balance for a long time.
We've used the ladder and assumed peer
review would be enough because
prohibition just seems extreme,
but many critics are now wondering
whether this is effective at keeping out
bad science because the NCRG disclosed
it and yet they still manage to shove
200 papers through the peer review
process.
Even the tobacco industry funded
research that slipped favorable articles
past the peer review process.
In my view,
the risk is too great.
I think that more journals should
seriously consider the prohibition model
when dealing with papers with an obvious
conflict of interest.
We live in a world where the truth is
not agreed upon very often,
and the last thing we need is for
science of beacon of objectivity to be
cluttered by bad actors who just want to
confuse the scientific consensus and
prevent progress.
So far,
what are the conclusions reached by your
organization,
in my opinion,
to single out smoking as a causal agent
is on the evidence today.
Complete down.
Gus,
thank you very much for your help.
Thank you very much for letting me put
our views forward.
You're going to have a cigarette share
and care
before you go.
We have a sponsor,
our very first sponsor,
so thank you to audible for sponsoring
this video.
You can get a free audio book and 38
trial by going to audible.com/break
or texting break the 500,
$500.
Most of the ideas you see on this
channel art inspired by books and one of
the ways I get through books is by
listening to them in the car,
at the gym,
walking,
whatever.
It's a great way to just take some books
down in your free time today.
I wanted to recommend hooked by Nir
Eyal,
which is about how engineer addictive
products,
and I think it goes right in line with
this video if you want to learn more.
So once again,
you can get a free audio book like
hooked by Nir Eyal or any book that you
choose from their amazement library by
going to audible.com/break
or texting break to $500.
$500.
Thanks for watching.